everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're gonna work on our side
drawer and we're using material UI to
give us some components to use material
design for a react project so just to
get everyone up to speed on the work
that's been done since yesterday stream
we have some testing available now so if
you check out the github repo the links
in the description if you check out the
repo you'll see
Harshit added some tests for the pages
that we have so far and I think that was
pull requests 19 so you could see
exactly what he changed if you go to the
pull request and her should also add it
in or I should say it got these all
styled properly and used I believe
flexbox to align these instead of what
did I use I think I was using just some
fixed alignment before which actually
now I look at this that that would have
been weird I didn't realize that we
aren't using a fixed header so wiesen
fixed here no we're not for some reason
I thought we were oh wow I was mistaken
so now I realize why everyone was
telling me not to use position:fixed
that would make no sense since we don't
have a fixed at Bart that's up so my
mistake I thought we did have fix that's
why I went with position fixed instead
of position:absolute but it doesn't
matter now so you can check out
everything that changed if you know you
look at the github repo check out the
last two pull requests as of right now
all the issues are closed so I'm gonna
try to get some more issues up there and
that way if anybody wants to give their
vice or discuss how we're gonna do
something then you can comment on the
issues or if you'd like to you know to
write some code or anything then you
know go ahead and take one of those
issues and try it out okay it looks like
alright Adam says the video is not
working it's paused is it is it like
that for everybody is anybody else
having trouble with the video let me
know everything looks alright from my
end but I could try to change something
let's see dose world says YouTube
notifications aren't working
occasionally YouTube notifications don't
work for the videos if I start them if I
schedule the stream within an hour of
when I'm actually gonna start the stream
it seems like the notifications don't
always work I did yeah you know what I
didn't get a notification saying I was
going to stream but I got one when I did
start the stream so it's on my phone so
that's the problem I was just caught up
doing some work on some other projects
and didn't get the stream scheduled so
later I'll try to schedule it earlier
tomorrow and and then hopefully
everybody will get two notifications
let's see
so I'm just going through live chat
really quickly hey everybody I see a lot
of people saying hi you can find if you
want to know when the best way to figure
out when the stream goes live so a few
people are talking about that number one
you can subscribe to this channel free
code camp YouTube channel and if you
have your notifications turned on then
you should get a notification both
before I stream and then when I stream
also if you follow me on Twitter which
my link to my Twitter account I believe
is in the description to this video if
you follow me on Twitter I am I always
post on on Twitter so I always tweet
about what I'm gonna do that day during
the stream and I try to do that so when
I schedule the stream immediately after
I tweet about it so those are the best
two ways to find out
alright so I'm gonna get started and
then I'll answer some questions in the
live chat so I do see some questions
there already so hang on we're gonna do
25 minutes of coding and then I'll take
a five-minute break I'll answer as many
questions as I can we'll do another 25
minutes of coding and then after that
I'll answer all the questions there in
the live chat so if you can stick around
I'll answer your question if for some
reason you can't watch until I get to
your question just check out the
recording of the video later on and I'll
answer your question you know no matter
what whether or not you're still still
around and the recording is usually
available a few minutes after I and the
stream alright so let me switch to this
screen and you can see some of the
additions here okay so I'm gonna make a
few adjustments you know with the size
and everything but for now this is this
is
looking good we don't have the actual
links in here yet you know these aren't
unreal links yet and then our search
doesn't work but right now we're not
pulling any any data so I'm not as
worried about the search we are gonna
make it so that when you click on this
little text input opens up here and then
you can close it so that's going to
happen at some point but like I said I'm
not that worried about getting the
search going until we actually have data
and can test it out so this is what we
have so far for our side drawer oops let
me set my timer here for 25 minutes this
we have so far for the the side drawer
so so we're going to do actually let me
start my let me start my server for n
grub and I'm gonna paste the link in the
live chat now and you all can check out
the site as we're editing it
all right
there yeah okay so the end Rock server
is working I see a lot of connections on
there
so check that out you can open that up
in your own browser use dev tools and
you know as soon as anything changes
locally for me it will refresh and
change for you as well alright so here's
what we're gonna add the logos good
that's actually I like the size on that
that's fine we're going to have in this
position a search bar and that wound up
being I do believe let's sue it mobile
so I need to think about we're gonna do
for mobile yeah right now we have
nothing going on and in terms of a
change up here so I'm not going to worry
about that for today's dream but what
I'm thinking is we're gonna have to cut
some things out to make this look
alright on mobile the this search button
is going to be cut out but then we'll
have one here on the sidebar so there
will be a search available that'll save
some space and decrease kind of the
complexity of you know where do these
things go or the logo where does this
all go whenever we want to expand this
you know so we don't even have to worry
about that at all so we're gonna have
that search input and then below it
we're gonna have menu items but they're
all going to be nested so you'll be able
to click it and then see submenu items
below and that'll be nice because it'll
allow us to include a lot of links
there'll be a visual hierarchy so
immediately users will be able to tell
like what section something belongs to
and also it won't be overwhelming at
first so potentially there could be a
lot of links on this site so the current
site at Franciscan ddu the current site
has a ton of links a lot of different
menus so it can be overwhelming
some users if they're not sure where to
find something this is going to be much
simpler at first look but then as you
click through the different levels
you'll be able to see a lot but
hopefully by kind of by nesting these
things it should make it kind of a nicer
kind of a nicer navigation experience it
looks like something's broken Phillip
says it's broken
Blake's this is broken what's what's
broken the the end Rock server let me
know if that's it if the site's broke
and the end rock servers broken let me
know it is it if it's working for some
people let me know as well
Justin says why would a beautiful school
so you have maybe you looked up the
website so good for you for sticking
around through that long load time for
the main website right now but yeah the
school does look it looks very nice
we're kind of up on a hill and just kind
of surrounded by trees and things and
the grounds crew that does a really nice
job of landscaping too so it's a nice
little campus
all right cool so let me check out let
me try to fix an grukk if I can get it
fixed here in just a minute or two then
I think it's worth it if I can't get it
fixed within a minute or so then we're
just pray just not gonna use it
hmm
okay and rock is at an older point in
time maybe I mean okay
that was it it looks like an grexit is
at an older point so goodness yes so
this keeps happening occasionally any
idea how we can fix this right now the
only way I can get this to work is if I
restart the the server and I can't just
restart immediately I have to stop it
wait for like 10 seconds and then
restart it if I restart it too fast it
doesn't work it's really weird so this
is gonna be a significant drawback for
us if this keeps happening frequently
all right so let me restart this now
I've had it off for a little bit okay I
think it should work no did it out work
all right yes okay work this time
so check it out see if it works now on
on on your version of n drop so
generates next server and dynamic class
things
class name conflicts okay so heart
should sing their class name conflicts
be which okay I was checking out the
airlock now interesting
all right well maybe I'll have to look
that up and see if if other people were
having the same issue and if they found
any solution there's not really any
obvious errors that I'm seeing on the
console I just had it open on my other
screen there are some errors but it
looked like they weren't exactly related
oh actually now I just open it again
there's a lot more errors Wow
oh good well let's get started on on
actually you're working on this side bar
and then maybe before sometime before
tomorrow stream I'll try to I'll try to
figure out what's going on and get that
working properly all right so I guess we
could put in let's put in our our nested
items first because I have this page
open on the material UI documentation
now so we'll go with that first and then
we'll do that that input I think the the
search input will be slightly more
complicated so let's let's get something
done first and then cycle that okay so
here's our nested list this is how it
wind up working so you see when we click
it we have a change in that icon our
menu items appear slightly indented okay
and then we click it again and it closes
so that's exactly what we want all right
so let's copy
we need our expand more and expand less
and we need our collapse all right let's
grab
let's grab all of this we're not going
to need it all but we'll remove some of
it but for now we're going to grab all
of that copy it and then paste it over
here into our our drawer component so we
already have that drawer j/s component
in our components folder and okay we
have our list items here which is
awesome so we can remove it yeah we can
remove it from here and I'm not sure if
we're gonna use the sub-header
I'm gonna leave it in for now we need to
collapse we don't need these icons the
inbox or the drafts icon or the send
icon we need to expand icons and we need
the butter yeah I think we will use the
divider as well okay you have those in
here now
we could add
let's add this nested in all right and
this is going to give us that
indentation for are nested items
I'm gonna try this this isn't exactly
how it had it in the and the example you
see yeah we have this in that bar okay
we are using the Styles theme and a bar
a harder shoot why why are we doing it
like this in at-large ass but then in
drawer we're not uh sort of not using
theme can we use theme will it make is
will it make a difference either way I'm
asking hardship because he's the one
that implemented a lot of this
let's see place where we're actually
trying to bring these styles and
okay so classes list all right it seems
like it's working in the same way class
classes route okay it seems like we're
using it in the same way so let's give
it a shot see if it works now we need
see which one we wants there we go
all right so we want this list item and
then the collapse and we need to nest
that within a list so we already have a
list and we have a list item in with our
our logo and then we have this this
other list item here which we're going
to overwrite for now okay great so we
need to add a click handler and States
to make sure we have okay good all right
and we're gonna have to switch this
yeah we're gonna have to change this
all right so right now we need to change
this to goodness all right we're gonna
have to make some changes so let's see
first off we need to make this class
temporary or extends component since we
got components and then we're not gonna
be able to do things like this now we
have this we need state we need this
clique so let's grab these and okay so
let's put these in first let's get rid
of these for now
let's see we need her yeah so we can put
these here and then within our render
function and we can have this and then
we're gonna need a return
oops
oh you know what we already had a return
I didn't even see that okay so we should
be alright if I remove this and let's
take out this and maybe one more yeah
one more bracket and that should be it
alright I'm not gonna worry too much
about formatting since we have the Auto
formatting setup
actually I'm it's odd that I'm not
getting its out of warnings right now
that's weird that's okay let's see what
kind of errors are getting seam is not
defined whoops okay
why don't even try to use theme oops
here okay so let me pass in theme we do
this there we go
weeks
and super must be either null or the
function not undefined where am I using
that all right let me check
all right I'm checking the live chat
hearts got a lot of words with all caps
in here so let me let me read through
some of this way another passage froze
see
okay this all right so I'm trying to
figure out what her she was saying they
are passed these are pastors proud of
all right so hard [ __ ] I'm not sure what
I was doing at the time you were saying
the things you did in the live chat so
at this point what what are you
suggesting then let's see it since I
probably messed up something as I was
copying pasting everything
what's my error message not
okay that's for my my
let's say this is
in case you haven't watched this stream
before part of the purpose of the stream
is to show me at my normal daily job
making mistakes and trying to work
through them so I don't practice this
ahead of time
so that's why I'm just kind of working
through this right now
all right well I hope to make sure at
least that I copied everything that I
needed from here
oh shoot
all right let's see what that did I'm
still getting the same error but that
that should have been changed anyway
you know what should I have this table
let's see
what's this horseshit submitted a PR
about this
all right so I have Harsha's PR open on
another screen here
it Shh yes
all right so hard [ __ ] let me check the
lodge
we're react component oh my goodness
this is the problem all right well that
was one problem okay great yes all right
that I was looking through hard stuff
and I'm like my stuff looks exactly the
same but it was the the capital so do go
thank you so much for catching that and
Harsha thanks for that as well and let's
see okay and also our sources saying you
don't need the handle click ok alright
my timer so my 25 minute timer is up so
let's do a short break right now five
minutes I'm going to go to the live chat
answer any questions you all have then
we'll come back sort out these errors
and and move on from there
so random person says what is material
you I from and what do you need to get
it
okay so material you I did I did not I
don't know what happened with that
anyway I thought I said it to the five
minute one so material UI is a framework
let's see if I can get so it's just a
bunch of react components that are
styled in the material design style so
it's free to use
you can you bring it into your project
you know with with NPM so you can npm
install bringing into your project and
just follow their documentation to you
know have kind of these pre-built
components so it really helps save a lot
of time you take quite a while to build
out all the components that they offer
so it's really helpful and yeah if you
have any more questions about it let me
know but I check out the docs they're
pretty straightforward
Philip says should I just merge master
to my fork to have it all updated yeah
if you have if you have fork the project
you'll definitely want to like
periodically update your fork with
what's in in the main repo that way if
you do end up submitting a pull request
then there'll be much less chance of
having a bunch of merge conflicts
Anthony says ask do you know all
programming language no I my I know
JavaScript and I know a little bit of
PHP I've done like build some WordPress
plugins and being able to like handle
form submissions file uploads just like
basic very basic security on handling
file uploads in PHP I've done a little
bit with Python enough like really basic
stuff I've done a tiny bit with Java on
John just messing around with making a
game with Java and I've also done a
little bit with c-sharp and some with
C++ so that's the extent of my
programming knowledge so the only
programming language that I would even
say that I'm I'm at all good with this
JavaScript but I know enough about a lot
of other ones that I could like kind of
get through like reading a little bit of
it and figuring out what's going on
Kristopher ask how many projects do you
usually work on at once I usually have
two or three going at once almost always
there's like one main one and some other
ones that I'm just fixing things on
currently in any given week right now
you know in terms of the last few weeks
I've worked on this project we have two
other react projects that I'm working on
and I just have some styling stuff to do
on a Salesforce based project and I'm
helping out someone in the IT department
with some some styling and and just kind
of like going through some old code and
doing some basically some code cleanup
stuff so was that like five five
projects right now that I can think of
that I'm working with but like I said
this is actually this one isn't even my
main one right now in terms of what I
spend my time on outside of the stream
so this is the only project that I'm
streaming consistently right now the
other projects or what I spend most of
my time on outside the stream and that's
mainly because they have those projects
need to be done sooner and then also I
think it's kind of nicer to do most of
the work for this on the stream and then
that way you all get to see a lot of it
and there's not like really huge periods
of of change like where I have to spend
most of the stream just explaining all
the things that change so sometimes that
happens and I got to do a lot of work
outside the stream just to get projects
done on time but for now when we're kind
of in the beginning stages I'll try to
work on other stuff and then save this
this project for for the stream all
right so my five-minute timer is up so
let's get back to this code and get past
some of the
Aires and then I'll come right back to
where I left off in the live chat okay
and see
all right
oh yes we got our 25 minute timer
started let's check out it's not defined
alright let's check this out and okay
hard should I see that you you merge the
are you submitted the pull request I'd
kind of like to work through this like
on the stream you know and with
everybody so I'm not gonna merge it
right now on the stream I may end up
merging it later if we can't get this to
work like right on the stream but for
right now list item icon is not defined
oops I forgot to take out these icons so
of course that's not gonna work okay so
if you remember I copied and pasted a
lot of this and then I removed a lot of
the imports well I removed the imports
but I forgot to take them out here so
it's looking for them and it can't find
them so let's go to where alright this
was here this is this starts what we
brought in right so we have inbox icon
let's remove that component and I think
there's one more actually there might be
two more so the star border we don't
need that and there's the last one
I will see maybe there wasn't another
one I thought there was all right let's
see if that did anything where am i
bringing this in oh goodness I didn't
even see that okay there we go all right
let's see what we get now whoops okay
awesome
so oops yeah so I am messing something
up so I see harsh it was saying
something about I added in some extra
stuff that I didn't need to so I guess I
copied over more than I needed to let me
go back to that that list so let's check
out so he's talking about state so he's
saying I copied over more than I needed
to in terms of handling the state so
let's check this out
and see what we're doing here with our
mmm
all right so hard [ __ ] and your PR let's
see did you put in okay so you you did
not bring in at least from what I'm
saying
okay so this was just converting it from
stateless functional to a class okay
okay great
okay so hard should explained a bit okay
that's what I was thinking as well so
basically I'm sure you all saw this
already but even before I did but right
now we have open for state but we have a
conflict right so we're using we're
using names we should not use be using
the same name so I think the simplest
thing is for me to change this open
items and then we'll leave all the
drawer stuff alone and then down here
we'll change this to open items and
let's see if that works for us oops okay
so I mean that's working in terms of
this but why are we getting did we have
this set you know we must have this set
to close on click a menu item click so
let's
let's check out the documentation for
our I guess for our drawer
and let's see we don't have the
responsive drawer this is the one we
have alright so let's see really we want
the API actually so let's go down to
this drawer API and see
[Music]
hmm
maybe it's not on here you transition
route on click leave it like that
[Music]
okay yeah so hard should I see what
you're saying you know for this one I
definitely wanted to do that so I wanted
to close automatically because we are
going to transition route but for this I
don't want it to happen here this is so
we need to change it for for just these
ones because those won't actually be
links see what we have here it was
actually did we bring in lists
sub-header i was thinking about changing
these two lists subheaders let's see
what we look we have here these are
lists
and I can't find her list
that is this item was text helps you
know we're in the API section anyway
area where are we using the list sub
header okay yeah maybe I don't want that
as a sub header all right Diego says
check the trigger on this menu item okay
let's
this so right now we have this is our
menu item to this handle click this is
our click handler here but what we have
are we passing this anything up yeah
actually we are let's check out our
layout component
okay so we are passing that down the the
state is held here in the parent
component so you see and the parent
component we have state drawer false
means it's closed true we be open and
then we have that toggle drawer here so
on drawer we're passing down whether or
not it's open or closed right so by
default we're passing down false and
then we're also passing this toggle
drawer down so the the events will come
up here and call this function it will
change the state and then that will be
passed back down so let's go back to our
drawer and on request closed toggle
drawer and then we have on click toggle
drawer okay so basically we have our on
click for toggle drawer here but we
don't want it there
Anitra okay so basically anywhere I
click within that div yeah it'll close
the shore so I hate to do it like this
but I'm not really sure I'm just not
really sure what to do let's see if
let's just try it see if we can put it
on this this list item let's see if if
this will work all right so we should we
click here nothing happens we click here
it closes great okay that's what we want
let's see if I can all right so I can
hit enter here and that it does that but
then if I I can't see if I can tab
trying to tap down to store alright so I
can't tab down that menu item alright so
I don't really like that so but this
works but the only thing I'm worried
about is I can't tab down to this item
using the keyboard it like highlights
both of these like the whole thing and I
can't navigate like that so I would it
would be nicer if I could have it works
so that you could navigate by keyboard
alone we can work on that but for now
this is closer to what we want not
perfect okay all right so let me just go
over kind of go over what just happened
in case I kind of was going around too
fast which sometimes when I get into it
and I think I'm almost like found a
solution I do go too fast so basically
what was happening is we had this
containing div here right that contains
everything inside this drawer right at
least all the items so it wasn't
stretching the full length but it
basically from here to here everything
in here was within that div so if you
clicked on anything in this area it
triggered close so what we did was we
just move that from this containing div
down to this item this list item and now
you can click on this or this and it
does not automatically close the drawer
but if we click on on this item right on
start it does close the drawer now what
we probably should do is move these now
that I look at it so here's the list
item and then we have
list underneath here and we'll keep
adding items to this list so it'll be
better if I think we end up putting
these classes these toggle classes here
on this list that way we won't have to
put it on every single list item because
we may end up having quite a few items
here so this will be a lot nicer to do
it like this
so I'm gonna move those let's test it
out so I can still click here this works
this works and then that works wonderful
okay awesome very cool all right so I
have about ten minutes left let's see
about adding in hmm yeah let's try to
add in this search input let's see if
there's any examples no I don't see any
examples here of using a search input
inside a list okay
so let's go this is really small we make
this bigger for everybody okay
let's go to our forms their text fields
is the name of this section so we're
gonna go to our text field and let's
grab one we're gonna want one with an
icon to see if they have that
and put adornments okay this is probably
what we want the input adornment so just
gonna quickly scroll through make sure
okay so this is probably what we want
let's check it out and it looks like
and put adornment and okay great so we
can just add in an icon here within this
input adornment component and we specify
the position which in this case end will
work for us
great okay so let's all right let's copy
all of this for now we're gonna have to
edit this of course whoops not all that
alright let's copy that and bring this
over and we're gonna want this right
after that that logo so let's go with a
list item and then all of this now let's
bring over we need to bring in here so
for an input that looks good
okay that looks good we also need to
bring in an icon and I know we're
already bringing in the icon here so
where we have for the app bar right I
thought we were bringing in an icon
weren't we
that search icon
oh okay alright so it looks like I guess
horseshit brought in and an SVG icon
into here okay that's cool let's see if
we can pull in a search icon the yeah so
we'll just grab let's grab this and use
it here oops wrong component say we
already yeah we're already bringing in
some icons
let's try search search icon see if it
works so down here where we brought in
this icon button
there we go visibility oh yeah we don't
want that we want search icon and put
that in here
icon button we don't need any icon we
don't need any click handler here on our
icon button we may not even need this
component at all may be able to take
that out I'll double check that you know
afterwards yeah we don't want it we just
want text so we can get rid of all of
this and just put text as the type we
don't need this state let's try this
search the state search and on change
this handle change let's just do handle
search change and okay so this is gonna
be controlled components so if you're
not really if you've never worked with
inputs and react one way to do inputs is
as a controlled component so let me walk
you through that I know I've gone over
this in previous streams but I assume we
have some people watching that hadn't
watched previously when we've done
components or controlled components so
here's what we're gonna do I actually
don't really care for this ID right now
I'm just gonna try to get rid of as much
as possible to simplify things you know
what I do need the ID just for the label
but I do want to change this to search
and she's just a search so remember just
like you can't use class you have to use
class name you also
can't use for you need to use html4 so
those are the two that come up most
often for me there may be some other
properties on you know HTML properties
that need to change but for now I can't
think of it so okay so here's how
controlled components going to work if
you notice the value for this component
is coming from the state and then when
we change we're gonna call this handle
search change function so let's scroll
up and write that function now so we
already have this handle click and we I
guess we could have just left that that
the name of that function as handle
change but handle search change I guess
immediately tells you what what's going
on handle search change and we're just
going to do this set State and we're
gonna do search and let's change the
state search
and at first let's just make this an
empty string and what we want to do is I
would see you takes this handle surge
see how we do this
how do we do this
like how we did this on the one do we
need I'm not gonna guess let's just go
here there's a a purr
unchanged textfield
handle surge toggle there's that input
text field search and a little input
change alright so I'm just checking out
okay so we have this in our container
component
there we go there we go that's where you
had to do okay um so let me bring you
target value okay so that's a previous
project so here we go II
there we go
so what's gonna happen here is when the
component first renders its gonna get
its value from state which currently is
nothing but then when you type in the
search input it'll fire off the search
function that handles search change
function and then it'll grab the value
that that's just been inputted and it'll
set that as this value here for search
okay then the input will get its value
from state right so it's kind of like
this circle so instead of it's all it's
kind of weird that the inputs value is
always coming from state it's not like
you're directly changing the value
there's this little roundabout thing
going on the background in terms of from
a user's perspective it works exactly
the same as a normal input but behind
the scenes it happens like this so
that's which you call controlled
component let me save that I don't think
it's gonna work because I think it's
gonna it's still looking for some Styles
that I have not brought in so let me
bring in some of those Styles I was to
form control and
do we have anything else without label
now we are using a label so I think we
just need form control so let's bring
that in and let's see if this will work
for us nope
icon button is not defined oh we didn't
bring in an icon button alright I'm not
even sure if we're gonna need icon
button anyway but let's bring it in now
just to make it work since our timer
already went off
all right great okay so here's our
search so you can see we type in and we
should have let's bring over yet so in
react we can see our value so here's our
value for that input and as we change
what's in the input you can see it
updates automatically
sorry that's kind of small hopefully you
see that but it's updating the state
automatically hey which is it's pretty
cool and then even if I went in here to
the value and change the value is gonna
let me change it thanks uh all right
it's not letting me change that text
usually I can just click right in there
and change it but anyway if it would let
me click in there and change it then I
can update it would automatically update
in here so not bad pretty cool I do need
to change the label though I never
changed the label so let me do that now
and then then we'll finish up and I'll
go to the live chat and I'll make sure
that I commit these changes right now so
you all can see it see the code for them
in the github repo so where we add up a
little bit huh yeah okay search
here we go so it says search awesome
obviously we're gonna change those
Styles a bit we don't want that
you know lime green color in there and
we may actually want to change the
Styles a bit more I have something else
in mind
but that's going to be one of those
things that is not necessary but if we
have time he'd be cool to put it in you
know this looks okay it functions in
terms of being able to input stuff it
functions of course the search isn't
working yet all right awesome let's
commit this I'm gonna bring over my
terminal she all can see how to commit
and you can see the test running and
everything in case you you know familiar
with that so let's do it get status just
to see right all the changes on our
drawer J's component which is good
that's what we wanted to see if we saw
some other components that have been
changed then that would be weird we
would want to check it out and see what
it changed since we haven't worked on
any other components that may have mean
that we only made a mistake and
accidentally edited something without
realizing it but this looks good so
we're gonna do a git commit and we're
gonna use the am flag a for add so we're
gonna add the the file okay add the
changes and commit them at the same time
and then the EM flag means we're going
to put in the commit message as well so
let's say we add search and nested list
to drawer okay now it's going to run
through this parts the auto formatting
whoa and it looks like the sub is
defined but never lose the former form
helps it protects us
okay all right not not bad this is kind
of cool this came up so we have two
errors that we've imported things and
never use them so this is very helpful
error message it tells us exactly what
component and draw is and then it tells
us where so line six in line 14 we need
just delete them so let's scroll up here
line 6 and line 14 which is now 13 we
need to get rid of form helper text
great now let's try this again
all right so we made it through the
linting and then it passed all these
tests right so we have a test for layout
index and app bar passed all our tests
and now it's ready to go
so we go get push origin since we're
just pushing you know right to the
master branch this is a little shortcut
normally we could say git push origin
master but this works as well all right
now all whatever we've done now is up on
the github repo you can also notice that
when we left this we had some weird
indentation stuff going on we had
semicolons at the end of some of these
really wasn't consistent now there are
no semicolons or indentation is all
fixed even down here on our components
look at this everything's everything's
looking nice
very consistent okay that's that that
automatic formatting that we have so the
same thing will happen for you if you
download this repo you can format the
code however you want but when it comes
time to commit it'll fix it all up for
you and then commit it so that
everything committed to the repository
will all have a uniform consistent look
and it'll still allow you to code in
whatever style that you're comfortable
with and then a little auto format for
you I think that's really useful you can
check out our package JSON to see how
that was set up and now let me scroll
back up in the live chat to where we
left off and at this point I'm gonna
answer all the questions so if you don't
want to stick around for the question
and answer session I totally understand
thank you so much for watching I'll be
back tomorrow around the same time 2:00
p.m. Eastern Time but if you have an
extra few minutes I'd love if you could
stick around and help me answer some
questions or ask some questions of your
own
I definitely benefit from your expertise
all right so if you do have any
questions please put them in the live
chat now when I get to the bottom of the
live chat I will end the stream so make
sure you get your questions in before
then if you don't want to ask your
question in front of everybody on the
live chat that's cool I totally
understand you can always send me a
direct message on Twitter or message me
on any other social media platforms
email me whatever you want and I'd be
happy to take a shot at answering the
question you know more privately okay
cool Harshit says he's added
notifications to Pomodoro timer so if i
refresh it should prompt me to enable
that I guess it didn't let's try to do a
hard refresh
that's a notification I do have it to
allow notifications that's weird you
know what harsh it may be I've already
allowed notifications but they're just
showing up on my main screen that's
probably the case and I probably don't
notice it because I'm usually looking at
this screen that you all are looking at
as well so off to keep keep my eye out
on my main screen to see if if that's
the case
see
all right so I'm just scrolling down
looking for some questions right now
okay there's a little bit of a
discussion about binding this so not
necessarily a question for me but I
think it may be useful for some of you
or just starting out and react so I'm
just going to address this briefly so
the discussion and a live chat is is
about this binding this so if you'll
notice we don't have this super and then
buying this down here for these
functions instead we're using arrow
functions so that's what we're doing a
handle click equals we have our
parenthesis and then our arrow here and
then inside here this works okay so that
would have been the same as if we had
bound this you know up here and find an
example I wish I had an example of us
using that but I don't I don't think I
have one that won't take me a few
minutes to get to but basically this is
all you need to do interact component so
you don't have to worry about binding it
separately you can just do everything
right here with an arrow function so
really nice a lot shorter and at least I
I think it it makes things a lot easier
I always thought it was kind of
cluttered up to have you know a bunch of
stuff your binding up at the top
haha at 2:30 p.m. my time so half hour
after he started the stream rook got the
YouTube notification that free code
campus lives sorry about that to anyone
who didn't get their notification on
time that potentially was my fault
because I started I scheduled the stream
so late that maybe that messed it up so
I apologize if that was me
I'll try to schedule the streams earlier
okay harsh it says that materiai is
actually really hard to test in unit
testing so he's going to submit a PR
probably submitted PR with end-to-end
testing that'll be really cool if we can
show on the stream that comparison
between how we're doing unit testing and
end-to-end testing I'm excited to check
out the difference and because I'm very
new to testing and I think it could be
helpful to some of the you know some of
the viewers here and then some of you in
the live chat that maybe are more
experienced with testing can you know
helping explain how it's working
Harshad says hi Jesse I just started
project five today and I went through
project five day one as a suggestion
please add the project five day four
project 5 day 6 etc bit at the start of
the video it's easier to read and follow
in the free code cam videos
alright I'm not sure
I'm not sure what you mean by that harsh
head so I'm sorry maybe I'm just I'm
reading that wrong I'm not understanding
so if you're still watching could you
clarify a little bit for for me what
what exactly you'd like me to add at the
start of the video I'm also gonna put
these all in one playlist as well so I'm
not sure if you're kinda you'd like that
if that's what you're referring to or
not
but I am gonna add these I was just
waiting to get a little bit more you
know video so now we're up to what is
this four videos for five I think it's
four so now it might it might be enough
that I could put it in its own playlist
you know separately from our main live
coding with Jessie playlist
all right so I think we're looking at
here right there we go okay so Brooke
had a question about what's the D
balance and that handle change function
so so you're using
Harshit set this up with with debounce
basically what that insures is that this
this function isn't firing like
constantly right so there's going to be
a little break because it doesn't really
need to fire constantly right and
Harshit used low - for this so check out
the low - docks on D bounce
okay
Harshit saying in install linter and
Lintz parser es linton parser es line
you know what I have I don't understand
why it wasn't working for me it was
working earlier and I don't know if I
was working on this project if it was
another project it's possible maybe that
I installed it and needed to like
restart and it worked in the other
window because I had to open that
afterwards so maybe I'll try to give
this a restart at some point and see if
it works for me then but I did have
actually stopped working ok now at least
some of it's working now so these little
red dots these are new this is a newer
system newer linting so I don't know I
don't know why it's working sometimes
and not other Suns
any courses would be nice if you add
issue / tasks at github so we can
collaborate with something yes
definitely I plan on adding some more
issues we did have some issues up but
they were all closed today so I need to
add some more but I definitely plan on
doing that so keep a lookout in the in
the issues especially as the project
starts to get bigger I can put a lot
more issues in there right now you know
we're just starting out so it's harder
for me to come up with really specific
things but I'm that's why I'm kind of
skipping over a lot of small style
changes because those are great issues
especially for beginners and I'd like in
case anybody's interested in just kind
of learning and getting started with
github it would be cool to have some you
know some issues that wouldn't be super
challenging for those people and if
nobody does them then that's that's cool
too I can just finish those up later on
but I'll add some of those in if I have
some time today before I go home I'll
add a man otherwise male try to get to
him tomorrow morning
Harshit says Jessie you should read the
contributing file of the repo and maybe
review it
okay yeah oh um I did read it before
when I merged then and it looked pretty
good I'll review it maybe more closely
and check it out but I really I liked
what you which you wrote so if you
haven't checked it out already check out
the contributing file in our github repo
and let me know if you have any
suggestions for it or feel free to open
a pull request if you'd like to change
some things but it's pretty solid harsh
that you did a good job on that so thank
you
let's see oh okay so Harsha thinks that
maybe the comment earlier from harsh ed
about what to add on the videos is the
de tag which I'm adding on the later
ones okay I didn't realize that I didn't
add that on the first one so if I didn't
know I'll go back and check it out oh
okay so harsh is saying I didn't add the
right Flynn thing I had his standard and
I need es Lintz okay
off to check that out actually let me
see where's my
my packaging preference is and packages
yep that's right yeah I did do the
standard linter so Stan interests and ER
formatter
okay so anyway so you are [ __ ] you're
saying I should go with with es lengthen
Alvie says hi guys new to the free code
camp community as well as coding in
general still wrapping my head around a
lot of it came a bit late to this live
stream sorry for the new question but
what would you use material for okay so
for a material with a teary UI basically
it just provides us with a bunch of
pre-made react components that are
already styled in the material design
you know style so it really helps us
save a lot of time because we don't have
to style them you know ourselves and
instead we can just adjust them a little
bit you know according to our needs so
that's what we's what's your UI for also
you know since material UI components go
through testing a lot of people use them
it's way more likely that their
components would act you'll behave as
they should in different environments
different browser device combinations so
that's why we would use you know
something like material UI it's the same
reason why you would use let's say
bootstrap if you're familiar with that
it just provides you with a lot of style
a lot of design already there so you
don't have to worry about it and it's
it's pretty reliable so and also welcome
to the free code camp community so you
know if you find these streams to be
helpful please you know come back and
join us contribute in the live chat and
and ask as many questions as you like
and don't worry if you think it's a noob
question that's not that's not a problem
I welcome any questions so don't don't
worry about that at all
and okay Brooke says code school is
having a free weekend this weekend so
awesome so if anybody is interested and
taking any courses you know tutorials on
code school
check it out this weekend
oh okay cool so harsh it's explaining
what I need to use an atom so if anybody
else would like to do this as well you
know maybe I'm gonna read out kind of
what Harshit saying so basically we're
using es lint in the project with
standard J's so what we need to do in
our editor and in this case I'm using
atom is use es lint with what I assume
with standard jazz rules and that'll
give us the same so we should use is the
linter es lint package so we can check
it out here so we'll enter Uslan sorry
for this being really small so check out
linter es lint and then install that and
[Music]
okay harsh it's actually paste it in the
command so you can install atom packages
from the command line if you like as
long as you downloaded a PM you can
install it so in this case we just use
the the interface you know the graphical
interface for that but either way it
will work so I'm at the bottom of the
live chat so I'm not I'm not gonna wait
and set this up you know completely but
you can see it doesn't actually take
that long so I'm assuming that we're
gonna have to put something in here for
the rules to change it up but that's
what we will be using for future shows
assuming I can get it to run okay
okay so heart should sing I should see
automatically cool
I should probably disable some of the
other stuff I'm using then right do we
no I shouldn't disable it okay all right
let's try it out then let shadow on this
side so just add a semicolon
okay so I'm not getting anything yet so
Ruxin restarted the editor okay all
right so I'll try restarting the editor
then later and and then try that out so
anyway thank you thanks everybody for
watching and for all your great
contributions in the live chat thanks
Harshit for for all the pull requests
and everybody else who helped out on
those issues kind of discussing what we
needed to do I really appreciate all of
your input and I'll be back tomorrow
with some more Wednesday yeah Wednesday
okay yeah I don't think I have anything
going on meeting wise tomorrow so it
should be around 2 p.m. and yeah so
until then have a great day and yeah see
you tomorrow